This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On a recent trip to Puerto Rico, producer Jacob Medina Gleason was introduced to a piece of family history. It's an old manila folder with a photo of her grandfather, Tomas Vélez Lópezpez attached to the front. In the picture, Tomás is a young 20-something with thick wavy hair and a full Tom Selleck mustache. And across the top of the folder, in big bold letters, it reads, The Division of Special Investigations and it has his case number. I don't know if they started from one, but if they did, he was 7,480. The intelligence division opened a case on Jaka's grandpa in the 1970s.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是Roman Mars。在最近的一次波多黎各之行中，制片人Jacob Medina Gleason接触到了一段家族史。那是一个旧的马尼拉纸文件夹，封面贴着她祖父Tomas Vélez López的照片。照片里的Tomas是一位20多岁的年轻人，留着浓密的波浪发和标志性的汤姆·塞立克式胡子。文件夹顶部用醒目的大字写着“特别调查处”，并标注了他的案件编号。我不知道他们是不是从1号开始编号的，但如果是的话，他是第7480号。情报部门在20世纪70年代为Jaca的祖父立了案。
The folder contains over 60 pages of notes and details about Tomas's life. Mundane things that are common in police files. His height, his weight, his license plate number. But there were other, less mundane details too. There's a line here that says, peligroso no. license plate number, but there were other less mundane details too. There's a line here that says, peligroso? No. So it's, is he dangerous?
文件夹里包含了60多页关于Tomas生平的笔记和细节。这些都是警察档案中常见的琐事。他的身高、体重、车牌号。但也有其他不那么寻常的细节。这里有一行字写着“危险吗？不”。所以，这是在问他是否危险。
And no, he apparently was not dangerous. Flipping through the folder, it was clear that my grandpa was part of a big investigation, but as I kept reading through the documents, I couldn't find what crime he was being accused of, or any allegations at all. Instead what I learned is that his case was about something else entirely. The file sums it up in one line. You know they're saying sort of purpose of the investigation and it's to determine his activities politically. This file the police kept on my grandpa is a type of folder known in Puerto Rico as a Carpeta. Carpetas were created to spy on supporters of Puerto Rican independence, and the folders
显然，他并不危险。翻阅文件夹时，很明显我祖父卷入了一场大规模调查，但随着我继续阅读这些文件，我找不到他被指控的罪名，甚至没有任何指控。相反，我了解到他的案件完全是另一回事。档案用一行字总结了调查目的，即确定他的政治活动。警察为我祖父保留的这份档案在波多黎各被称为“Carpeta”（档案夹）。这些档案夹是为了监视波多黎各独立运动的支持者而建立的，而这些文件夹
were one part of a decades-long surveillance operation which tracked more than 150,000 Puerto Ricans. The goal of the government's surveillance project was to intimidate and suppress the political movement, one that Jaca's grandfather belonged to. Your grandpa was a dreamer. And his first dream was having his nation free, was having his nation free, free from the power of the United States. That was his first love. When I met him, he loved it more than me. Truly. I mean, truly.
是长达数十年的监视行动的一部分，追踪了超过15万名波多黎各人。政府监视项目的目标是恐吓和镇压Jaca祖父所属的政治运动。“你祖父是个梦想家。他最初的梦想是让国家获得自由，让国家摆脱美国的力量。那是他的初恋。当我遇见他时，他爱那个梦想胜过爱我。真的，我是说真的。”
This is my grandma Nancy. If you can't already tell, Abuela Nancy is New Yorkican, down to her bones. And she told me that she actually met my grandpa because of the independence movement. We both sold periodico claridad. The two of them first ran into each other selling a pro-independence newspaper on the same street corner. Then one day he told me, hey, you can't take my corner. You gotta go sell somewhere else. That was like, I said, well, uh-uh.
这是我的祖母Nancy。如果你还没看出来，Abuela Nancy骨子里就是个地道的纽约波多黎各人。她告诉我，她其实是因为独立运动才认识我祖父的。“我们都卖《Claridad》报。”他们俩第一次相遇是在同一条街角兜售支持独立的报纸。“有一天他告诉我，嘿，你不能占我的地盘。你得去别处卖。我说，嗯，才不呢。”
That's how it all started. We had a very, very sweet friendship. My grandma also told me that after their little meet-cute, the government opened a carpeta on her, too. They started surveilling me when we two got together. Mine wasn't even as big as his. My grandpa Tomás died years ago, so I never got to ask him about any of this. But what I do know is that he, like a lot of Puerto Ricans, served in the US Army.
一切就是这样开始的。我们有着非常非常甜蜜的友谊。祖母还告诉我，在他们那次可爱的邂逅之后，政府也为她建立了一个档案夹。“我们在一起后，他们就开始监视我了。我的档案还没他的大呢。”我祖父Tomas多年前就去世了，所以我从未有机会问他这些事。但我知道的是，像许多波多黎各人一样，他曾在美军服役。
It was not lost on him that despite being a US citizen, Puerto Rico was not really a part of the United States. So he spent his life right up until his later years fighting for Puerto Rican independence. We were activists. We were always activists. Wherever there was something to do and something to fight for, we were there.
他很清楚，尽管身为美国公民，波多黎各并不是美国真正的一部分。所以他一生直到晚年都在为波多黎各的独立而战。“我们是活动家。我们一直是活动家。无论哪里有事可做，有仗可打，我们就在那里。”
For years, decades even, my grandpa's carpeta wasn't sitting in some government building or archive, but was buried in the back of my abuela's closet. All over Puerto Rico, thousands of these carpetas are lying around, perhaps in some other abuelas' closet. And each one, in its own way, provides a glimpse into the long and often ugly relationship between Puerto Rico and the United States. Puerto Rico has been a colony since the Spanish first arrived on the island of Burinque 500
多年来，甚至几十年来，我祖父的档案夹并没有放在什么政府大楼或档案馆里，而是埋在我祖母衣柜的深处。在整个波多黎各，成千上万这样的档案夹散落在各处，也许就在其他祖母的衣柜里。每一个档案夹都以其独特的方式，让我们得以一窥波多黎各与美国之间漫长且往往丑陋的关系。自500年前西班牙人首次抵达布林克岛（Burinque）以来，波多黎各一直是一个殖民地。
years ago. And from the very beginning, resistance defined the identity of the island of Burinque 500 years ago, and from the very beginning, resistance defined the identity of the island. In fact, the very idea of being Puerto Rican was born out of this tension between the colonized and the colonizer. The first time that the term Puerto Rican appears in the Spanish colonial record, it is in the early 1700s when a military official is complaining about all these Puerto Ricans, bastards of Spanish military generals. And so it is used to refer to Puerto Ricans, people from the archipelago, as bastards.
从一开始，抵抗就定义了这个岛屿的身份。事实上，“波多黎各人”这一概念正是诞生于被殖民者与殖民者之间的这种张力之中。在西班牙殖民记录中，“波多黎各人”一词最早出现在18世纪初，当时一位军事官员抱怨这些“波多黎各人”，称他们是西班牙军事将领的私生子。因此，它被用来指代波多黎各人，即来自群岛的人，意为“私生子”。
This is Jorrell Meléndez Padillo. He's an assistant professor of Latin American and Caribbean history at the University of Wisconsin Madison and author of the book Puerto Rico, A National History. Jorrel says that despite the Spanish crown's original intent to demean, people on the island embraced the term Puerto Rican, using it to rally around a shared identity. I think that Puerto Rican identity has always been constructed in opposition to colonialism.
这是Jorrell Meléndez Padillo。他是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校拉丁美洲和加勒比历史系的助理教授，也是《波多黎各：一部国家史》一书的作者。Jorrel说，尽管西班牙王室最初的意图是贬低，但岛上的人们接受了这个词，并用它来凝聚共同的身份认同。“我认为波多黎各人的身份认同一直是在反殖民主义的对立面中构建出来的。”
It is an affirmation of being something different from Spain. In the 19th century, hostility between the Spanish Empire and its colonies sparked a number of revolutions throughout the Caribbean. Puerto Ricans saw uprisings taking place all around them in the Dominican Republic and Cuba, and wanted in on the action. Which is when the United States entered the equation. In 1898, during the Spanish-American War,
这是对“与西班牙不同”的一种肯定。19世纪，西班牙帝国与其殖民地之间的敌意在整个加勒比地区引发了多次革命。波多黎各人看到多米尼加共和国和古巴周围发生的起义，也想参与其中。这时，美国介入了。1898年，在美西战争期间，
the United States presented themselves as liberators to the Puerto Rican people. But by the time the dust settled and the US had beaten the Spanish, they did not give Puerto Rico independence. Instead, they annexed it. At the time when a US territory was annexed, the next step for it was statehood. That's just how territories had worked since the founding of the country.
美国以解放者的姿态出现在波多黎各人民面前。但当尘埃落定，美国击败西班牙后，他们并没有给予波多黎各独立，而是将其吞并了。当时，当一个美国领土被吞并时，下一步通常就是成为州。这就是该国建国以来领土运作的方式。
A swath of land would be taken, a local government would form, and the territory would become a state. But, when the US acquired the Philippines,, Guam and Puerto Rico, lots of Americans were like, I don't know about all that. Americans in general did not like the idea of giving statehood to places inhabited by a majority of people who they didn't perceive as white. This is Christina Bonsacraos, a professor of constitutional law at Columbia Law School. They didn't think that the people of these islands could be properly assimilated into American culture,
一块土地被占领，建立地方政府，然后领土成为一个州。但是，当美国获得菲律宾、关岛和波多黎各时，许多美国人表示怀疑。美国人普遍不喜欢将州权授予那些他们认为非白人占多数的地方。这是哥伦比亚大学法学院宪法学教授Christina Bonsacraos。“他们不认为这些岛屿上的人民能够适当地融入美国文化，”
and yet instead of just leaving them alone, the United States took them anyway. And so then we've got this debate. What are we going to do? Should we have them as territories? Why were we annexing them? What's going to happen next? These questions went all the way up to the Supreme Court in a series of cases called the Insular Cases. In these arguments, the court debated whether or not the Constitution applied to all of these newly annexed territories. And the answer to that was a resounding sort of?
然而，美国并没有放任他们，还是占领了他们。于是就有了这场辩论：我们该怎么办？应该让他们作为领土吗？我们为什么要吞并他们？接下来会发生什么？这些问题一直闹到了最高法院，引发了一系列被称为“岛屿案件”的诉讼。在这些辩论中，法院讨论了宪法是否适用于所有这些新吞并的领土。而答案是一种响亮的“算是吧？”
It ended up essentially saying that Puerto Rico was not part of the United States in a more general sense. But it also said that Puerto Rico wasn't foreign. And so it came up with this language. Puerto Rico and the other territories by implication, that is the other new ones, the Philippines and Guam, are foreign to the United States in a domestic sense. And also, the court said, they are domestic in a domestic sense. And also the court said they are domestic in an international sense.
最终，法院实质上认为波多黎各在更广泛的意义上不是美国的一部分。但它也说波多黎各不是外国。于是它提出了这种措辞：波多黎各和其他领土（暗示指菲律宾和关岛）在“国内意义上”是外国，同时法院又说，它们在“国际意义上”是国内的。
If foreign in a domestic sense and domestic in an international sense is complete gibberish to you, that's because it is. Basically, the case is determined that the Constitution only applied to Puerto Rico as the U.S. saw fit because it wasn't a state, and then used this obscure language to explain away why it wouldn't become one. It's a two-step process. Annex and incorporate. And they were not planning to incorporate Puerto Rico. The Foraker Act and the Jones Act gave Puerto Ricans the ability to elect their own legislature and granted citizenship.
如果“国内意义上的外国”和“国际意义上的国内”对你来说完全是胡言乱语，那是因为它确实如此。基本上，这些案件判定宪法仅在美方认为合适时才适用于波多黎各，因为它不是一个州，然后用这种晦涩的语言来解释为什么它不会成为一个州。这是一个两步走的过程：吞并和合并。而他们并不打算合并波多黎各。《福勒法案》和《琼斯法案》赋予了波多黎各人选举自己立法机构的权利，并授予了公民身份。
So Puerto Ricans were citizens, but not totally citizens. And they could hold elections, but they still had no representation in Congress. As you could imagine, all this vague, incoherent language pissed a lot of people off. Puerto Rico had been a colony for hundreds of years by this time, and their fate was always being decided for them by outside forces. And within Puerto Rico, no one voiced their frustration with the island's status more loudly than the leader of the Nationalist Party, Pedro Alviso Campos. It was very similar to the Puerto Ricans. The Puerto Ricans should not be born.
所以波多黎各人是公民，但不是完全的公民。他们可以举行选举，但在国会中仍然没有代表权。你可以想象，所有这些模糊、不连贯的措辞激怒了很多人。到那时，波多黎各已经做了几百年的殖民地，他们的命运总是由外部力量决定。在波多黎各内部，没有人比民族主义党领袖Pedro Albizu Campos更强烈地表达对岛屿地位的不满了。“这和波多黎各人非常相似。波多黎各人不应该出生。”
Yes, but when the black people are the sons of the Yankees, we need the Puerto Ricans to put their backpacks on top of them so they can go and kill themselves. Starting in the 1930s, Albizu Campos led the Nationalist Party, which was one of the strongest voices in the Puerto Rican independence movement. Albizu Campos is a fascinating individual. Pedro Albizu Campos was a Harvard-educated lawyer, Afro-descendant. He had great rhetoric. He would spit fire. He dominated a crowd when he spoke and he spoke about the ills of Puerto Rico. A lot of what Albiso Campos was responding to came from Supreme Court cases that set up the political dynamic between the U.S. and Puerto Rico.
“是的，但当黑人是洋基佬的儿子时，我们需要波多黎各人把背包背在他们身上，这样他们就可以去自杀。”从20世纪30年代开始，Albizu Campos领导了民族主义党，这是波多黎各独立运动中最强有力的声音之一。“Albizu Campos是一个迷人的人物。Pedro Albizu Campos是一位受过哈佛教育的律师，是非洲裔。他有很强的修辞能力。他会喷火。他演讲时能掌控全场，他谈论波多黎各的弊病。”Albizu Campos回应的很多内容都来自确立美波政治动态的最高法院案件。
He wanted Puerto Ricans to see that this relationship made them second class citizens, and he wanted them to get mad. There were peaceful protests that shined a light on Puerto Rico's colonial status. But in 1935, Puerto Rican police, under the control of the U.S., killed a number of independence protesters. Months later, in response, some in the independence movement killed the police chief. After that, the U.S. determined that the Nationalist Party wasn't a political party, but a bunch
他希望波多黎各人看到这种关系使他们成为二等公民，并希望他们感到愤怒。当时有和平抗议活动揭露了波多黎各的殖民地位。但在1935年，受美国控制的波多黎各警察杀害了一些独立抗议者。几个月后，作为回应，独立运动中的一些人杀死了警察局长。此后，美国认定民族主义党不是一个政党，而是一群
of insurrectionists. And they were not afraid to use violence. And that is something that authorities feared. At first, Alviso Campos and the Nationalist Party tried to seek change through the ballot box, but the scales were always tipped against them. The US held a firm grip over the electoral system on the island, and basically every other lever of power too. And so, Alvizu Campos determined that they couldn't gain independence within a system
暴乱分子。他们不惧怕使用暴力。而这正是当局所担心的。起初，Albizu Campos和民族主义党试图通过投票箱寻求变革，但天平总是向他们倾斜。美国牢牢控制着岛上的选举制度，基本上也控制着其他所有的权力杠杆。因此，Albizu Campos断定他们无法在一个旨在压迫他们的系统中获得独立。
designed to oppress them. He declared that the Nationalist Party would withdraw from electoral politics so long as the U.S. was in power. Freedom wasn't going to be earned. They needed to take it. In the 1930s, hoping to restore order to the island, the United States appointed a new governor to oversee Puerto Rico. He militarized the police and jailed political opponents, including Albi-Sucampos.
他宣布，只要美国还在掌权，民族主义党就会退出选举政治。自由不是靠乞求得来的，他们必须夺取它。20世纪30年代，为了恢复岛上的秩序，美国任命了一位新总督来监管波多黎各。他将警察军事化，并监禁了包括Albizu Campos在内的政治对手。
The governor also authorized a new surveillance operation, one that would keep tabs on people they suspected to be part of the independence movement. This was the beginning of the Carpetas. Basically the way it would work was, it was sort of like a three strike system. That's Christopher Gregory Rivera. He's a photographer and artist who's done extensive research on Carpetas. He says that the government had a whole process for determining who was deemed suspicious enough to have one opened on them.
总督还授权了一项新的监视行动，旨在监视那些被怀疑参与独立运动的人。这就是“档案夹”（Carpetas）的开端。“基本上它的运作方式就像一个三振出局系统。”这是Christopher Gregory Rivera。他是一位摄影师和艺术家，对档案夹进行了广泛的研究。他说，政府有一整套流程来确定谁被认为足够可疑，从而需要为他们建立档案。
If I was a heavily surveilled person and we had a coffee, they would open an index card on you. And then if you never got any more cards, then you'd probably kind of fall off the radar. But if they saw you with somebody else or they saw you at a rally, you'd get another card. And sort of through that process, they kept track of connections. And when you got three of these index cards, then they would actually formally open a carpeta on you.
“如果我是一个被严密监视的人，我们一起喝了杯咖啡，他们就会为你建立一张索引卡。如果你之后再也没有收到更多的卡片，你可能就会从雷达上消失。但如果他们看到你和别人在一起，或者看到你参加集会，你就会得到另一张卡片。通过这个过程，他们追踪了人际关系。当你集齐三张索引卡时，他们就会正式为你建立一个档案夹。”
At the time, it was generally known within the independence movement that the government was watching. But how close and in what ways remained a mystery? The police, of course, didn't have the manpower to surveil each and every person who sympathized with the cause. And so they paid friends, neighbors, and colleagues to do a lot of the dirty work.
当时，独立运动内部普遍知道政府在监视。但监视的程度和方式仍然是个谜。当然，警察没有人力去监视每一个同情该事业的人。所以他们花钱雇佣朋友、邻居和同事来做很多肮脏的工作。
This, of course, created an obvious incentive. If you had something to say, you get paid. Or if you were in trouble with the law for whatever reason, you could get out of trouble by helping the police. And at a time when work was hard to come by on the island, lots of people suddenly had lots to say. From my perspective, having read a lot of them and talking to people who were surveilled and scholars and other researchers, you know, a lot of the information is like made up.
这当然产生了一种明显的激励机制。如果你有话要说，你就能得到报酬。或者如果你因为某种原因惹上了法律麻烦，你可以通过帮助警察来摆脱困境。在岛上工作难找的时候，很多人突然间有了很多话要说。“从我的角度来看，读过很多档案，并与被监视者、学者和其他研究人员交谈后，你知道，很多信息都是编造的。”
Christopher says that despite the bad information, the Carpetas still served a purpose for the Puerto Rican government. It had the effect of making people in the independence movement feel watched, which made organizing harder. The Carpetas were an off-the-book means of suppression while the state created on-the-book ways to criminalize their activity. And the size of the Carpeta indicated how aggressively a person was being surveilled. A person with a small Carpeta might never see a cop, while a person with a three-foot-tall carpeta might
Christopher说，尽管信息不准确，但档案夹对波多黎各政府仍然有用。它让独立运动中的人们感到被监视，这使得组织工作变得更加困难。档案夹是一种非正式的镇压手段，而国家则创造了正式的方式来将他们的活动定罪。档案夹的大小表明了一个人被监视的程度。一个档案夹很小的人可能永远见不到警察，而一个档案夹有三英尺高的人可能
have police stationed outside their home and business day after day. The heavier the carpeta, the heavier it weighed on a person's life. In 1948, the Puerto Rican government passed a law that made it a crime to write, meet, or speak about independence. The U.S. had entered the McCarthy era, and this fear of communism trickled down into its relationship with Puerto Rico as well. There was a fear of any kind of radical person, including Puerto Rican nationalists. Soon, anyone sympathetic to the cause or even questioning the government would find themselves
会日复一日地有警察驻扎在他们的家和公司外。档案夹越重，对一个人的生活压力就越大。1948年，波多黎各政府通过了一项法律，将书写、集会或谈论独立定为犯罪。美国进入了麦卡锡时代，这种对共产主义的恐惧也渗透到了它与波多黎各的关系中。人们对任何激进分子都感到恐惧，包括波多黎各民族主义者。很快，任何同情该事业甚至质疑政府的人都会发现自己
blacklisted. The police officers would show up to where you worked and they would talk to your boss and be like, oh, you know, we're investigating this person because they're, you know, a little subversive or we're investigating them criminally. And more often than not, most people would actually get fired from their jobs. Frustration in the independence movement was growing, especially when the island was granted a new status, one that provided the illusion of independence. In 1952, the U.S. decided it was time for things to change with Puerto Rico. Countries around the world were decolonizing their territories, and suddenly having a colony
被列入黑名单。“警察会出现在你工作的地方，他们会和你的老板谈话，说，哦，你知道，我们正在调查这个人，因为他们有点颠覆性，或者我们正在进行刑事调查。大多数情况下，大多数人真的会被解雇。”独立运动中的挫败感在增长，尤其是当该岛被授予一种新的地位时，这种地位提供了一种独立的幻觉。1952年，美国决定是时候改变波多黎各的情况了。世界各国的殖民地都在去殖民化，突然间拥有一个殖民地
was not a good look anymore. So the U.S. allowed Puerto Ricans to elect their own governor and ratify their very own constitution and bill of rights. And with all these big changes, Puerto Rico suddenly had the look, even the smell of a sovereign country. And with these changes came a new name, the Commonwealth of Puerto Rico.
看起来不再那么光彩了。因此，美国允许波多黎各人选举自己的总督，并批准他们自己的宪法和权利法案。随着所有这些重大变化，波多黎各突然有了主权国家的样子，甚至气味。随着这些变化，出现了一个新名字：波多黎各自由邦（Commonwealth of Puerto Rico）。
So what happens? Puerto Rico becomes a Commonwealth, and this debate begins. What just happened? We now have a constitution, we have self-government. Are we done? Did we decolonize? For some Puerto Ricans, the answer to whether or not the island had decolonized was an emphatic yes. In their eyes, the island had achieved what people had been clamoring for all along. More autonomy and an ability to elect their own leaders, all while
那么发生了什么？波多黎各成为了自由邦，辩论开始了。刚才发生了什么？我们现在有了宪法，有了自治。我们完成了吗？我们去殖民化了吗？对于一些波多黎各人来说，关于该岛是否去殖民化的答案是肯定的。在他们看来，该岛已经实现了人们一直呼吁的目标：更多的自治权和选举自己领导人的能力，同时
still maintaining a relationship with the US. In other words, all the benefits of being an American while still being able to call yourself Puerto Rican. Commonwealth supporters described their status as the best of both worlds because we had guaranteed citizenship and guaranteed union with the United States, but also a lot of autonomy, you know, kind of like an independent country, but also kind of like a state. But in my opinion and the opinion of its opponents, it was really the worst of both worlds because you are subject to the power of Congress and you're pretending you're decolonized. To Christina and many others, the term commonwealth wasn't a real change in political status. Sure, Puerto Ricans had more autonomy, but they didn't have total autonomy.
仍然保持与美国的关系。换句话说，既拥有美国人的所有好处，又能称自己为波多黎各人。自由邦的支持者将他们的地位描述为“两全其美”，因为我们有保障的公民身份和与美国的联合，但也拥有很多自治权，有点像独立国家，又有点像一个州。但在我看来，以及在反对者看来，这实际上是“两败俱伤”，因为你受制于国会的权力，却假装自己已经去殖民化了。对Christina和许多其他人来说，“自由邦”这个词并不是政治地位的真正改变。当然，波多黎各人有了更多的自治权，但他们没有完全的自治权。
Puerto Rico is subject to the control of Congress, and Congress can run the show, and it can only have a constitution if Congress lets it. And if Congress wants to take power away, it can. In other words, the term commonwealth was merely a cover, a word that helped Americans shed their belief that they had a colony, while at the same time introducing even more uncertainty into the day-to-day lives of Puerto Ricans. This is really how the United States has divided and conquered us. It basically gaslit us into not knowing what Puerto Rico's status is. We ourselves can't define commonwealth, or
波多黎各受国会控制，国会可以掌控一切，只有在国会允许的情况下才能拥有宪法。如果国会想收回权力，它就可以这样做。换句话说，“自由邦”这个词仅仅是一个掩护，一个帮助美国人摆脱“他们拥有殖民地”这一信念的词，同时给波多黎各人的日常生活带来了更多的不确定性。“这确实是美国如何分而治之我们的方式。它基本上是在煤气灯效应下让我们不知道波多黎各的地位是什么。我们自己无法定义自由邦，或者”
at least we can't agree on a definition. And so we just argue ourselves to death. And the United States doesn't have to do anything. They can just keep having a colony. For some in the independence movement, this persistent frustration boiled over into awful acts of violence. In March of 1954, four Puerto Rican nationalists entered Congress and opened fire. No one was killed, but five people were injured. The shooting ended up intensifying government surveillance on the independence movement.
至少我们无法就定义达成一致。所以我们只是争论到死。而美国什么都不用做。他们可以继续拥有一个殖民地。对于独立运动中的一些人来说，这种持续的挫败感演变成了可怕的暴力行为。1954年3月，四名波多黎各民族主义者进入国会并开火。没有人死亡，但有五人受伤。这次枪击事件最终加剧了政府对独立运动的监视。
It also deepened ideological divisions over Puerto Rico's status. After the 1950s, the political alliances on the island generally fell into one of three camps. People who supported the Commonwealth, the people who wanted to see Puerto Rico on the path to statehood into the United States. And then there were people like my grandparents, those who fought for full independence and saw statehood as just another form of colonialism. We belong too, but we're not part of. And that is so degrading for me. The disgrace of being a colony. When I spoke with my grandma Nancy, she was a little nervous to be at the other end of my mic.
它也加深了关于波多黎各地位的意识形态分歧。20世纪50年代后，岛上的政治联盟大致分为三个阵营：支持自由邦的人，希望看到波多黎各走上成为美国一州之路的人，还有像我祖父母那样的人，他们为完全独立而战，并将州权视为殖民主义的另一种形式。“我们属于这里，但我们不是其中的一部分。这对我来说太丢人了。作为殖民地的耻辱。”当我与祖母Nancy交谈时，她对坐在麦克风的另一端感到有点紧张。
And given this long history of surveillance, and having just spent the better part of a day flipping through my grandpa's carpeta, I totally get that. Still, she was able to tell me about what landed both of them on the government's watch list, and everything that came after. So, the man used to belong to the FUPI. That's the Federación Universitaria Pro Independencia. And with that group in the university, he traveled to Cuba two times. The University of Puerto Rico was and has always been a place where independentistas
考虑到这段漫长的监视历史，以及刚刚花了一天时间翻阅我祖父的档案夹，我完全理解。尽管如此，她还是能够告诉我他们两人是如何进入政府监视名单的，以及后来发生的一切。“那个男人曾经属于FUPI。那是大学独立促进联合会。在大学里，他随那个团体去了两次古巴。”波多黎各大学一直以来都是独立派人士
could find one another. And when my grandpa returned from his years in the army, the FUPI really spoke to him. My grandma told me that between his affiliation with this group, That's strike one. and traveling to Cuba twice, That's strike two and strike three. all that was enough to not only put him on the government's radar but get him a full-blown carpeta. Do you feel like grandpa knew and you knew that
可以找到彼此的地方。当我祖父从军队服役多年回来时，FUPI真的引起了他的共鸣。祖母告诉我，他与这个团体的联系，“那是第一击”；以及两次前往古巴，“那是第二击和第三击”。所有这些不仅足以让他进入政府的雷达，还让他获得了一个完整的档案夹。“你觉得祖父知道，你也知道
you guys were being surveilled? He knew, yeah, yeah, he knew it. The only thing nobody could prove it at that time. My grandparents, like many other people in the independence movement, could at that point only speculate that they were being watched, or to what extent. Maybe it was a car parked in front of the house, or a stranger in the corner of a restaurant where they were having dinner. But it was always a strong hunch, never proof. But soon a scandal would reveal just how deep surveillance on the island ran and supply all of the proof they needed. The story of how the Carpetas ended up being revealed to the public starts with the murder
你们被监视了吗？”“他知道，是的，他知道。只是当时没有人能证明这一点。”我的祖父母，像独立运动中的许多其他人一样，当时只能猜测他们被监视了，或者监视到了什么程度。也许是停在房子前的一辆车，或者是他们吃晚餐时餐厅角落里的一个陌生人。但这总是一种强烈的预感，从未有证据。但很快，一场丑闻将揭露岛上的监视有多深，并提供他们所需的所有证据。关于档案夹如何最终向公众揭露的故事始于谋杀
of two young activists. The case is known as the Cerro Maravilla murders. There are a lot of twists and turns in this case, but we'll keep it to only what you need to know. As part of this massive surveillance operation, the Puerto Rican police had lots of informants. One informant was a young man named Alejandro Gonzalez Malave. He was recruited by the intelligence division when he was still in high school. The job? To embed with young up-and-coming people in the independence movement. And so Malave has this deep cover. I mean, nobody is gonna suspect that somebody who has been involved in the movement since high school is a police officer.
两名年轻活动家。此案被称为“Cerro Maravilla谋杀案”。这个案件有很多曲折，但我们只讲你需要知道的部分。作为这项大规模监视行动的一部分，波多黎各警察有很多线人。其中一名线人是一个名叫Alejandro Gonzalez Malave的年轻人。他在高中时就被情报部门招募了。工作是什么？潜入独立运动中年轻有为的人群中。Malave有这种深层掩护。没人会怀疑一个从高中起就参与运动的人会是警察。
So in a way, this is like this James Bond, like, ultra agent, you know, that is recruited and goes through the ranks. In college, Malave infiltrated a subgroup within the independence movement as an undercover agent. And while undercover, Malavé convinced two young independentistas to sabotage a radio tower. As part of the operation, the group needed to carjack a taxi and drive up to the tower. However, when Malavé and the rest of the group arrived at the location, a bunch of police officers were waiting for them. It was a trap. They're literally knelt on the ground
所以从某种意义上说，这就像詹姆斯·邦德式的超级特工，被招募并晋升。在大学里，Malave作为卧底特工渗透进了独立运动的一个小组。在卧底期间，Malave说服两名年轻的独立派人士去破坏一座无线电塔。作为行动的一部分，该小组需要劫持一辆出租车并开车前往塔楼。然而，当Malave和小组其他人到达地点时，一群警察正在等他们。这是一个陷阱。他们被强迫跪在地上，
and executed point blank by a group of about 10 police officers, which were coordinating between the intelligence division, the police officers, and also the FBI. So there is federal buy-in on this whole thing. And they're executed point blank with no trial. A few days later, the governor released a statement in support of the officers, calling them heroes.
被大约10名警察近距离处决，这些警察在情报部门、警察和联邦调查局之间进行协调。所以整个事情都有联邦政府的支持。他们没有经过审判就被近距离处决了。几天后，总督发表声明支持这些警察，称他们为英雄。
The police had said they were acting in self-defense when the young men shot at them, and that they had told the men to surrender. But there was another person there that night who witnessed the whole thing. The taxi driver that was kidnapped actually didn't leave. And so he heard the whole thing and he heard the young men crying for help. And he became a key witness to uncover the fact that there was no resistance.
警方称他们在年轻人向他们开枪时是出于自卫，并且他们曾命令这些人投降。但那天晚上还有另一个人目睹了整个过程。被绑架的出租车司机实际上并没有离开。他听到了整个过程，听到了年轻人呼救的声音。他成为了揭露“没有抵抗”这一事实的关键证人。
These weren't quote unquote terrorists, that there was something more at play. That opened an investigation into these two young men and to the murder. What came next was many years of trials that were broadcast all over the island. My grandma remembers listening to the trial on the radio with my grandpa.
这些人不是所谓的“恐怖分子”，背后还有更深层的东西。这开启了对这两名年轻人和谋杀案的调查。接下来是多年在全岛广播的审判。祖母记得和祖父一起在收音机里听审判。
And that's where I found out one of the persons that was killed in Sergio Maravilla was his friend. They had studied all high school together. And that's when we really knew that, hey, this is serious. The trial dominated the airwaves, and it was on the radio that the truth about the Carpetas finally came to light. One of the police officers from the intelligence division, from the police, basically in a heated argument on a radio program, basically blurted it out. He was like, everybody knows that the police has files on the Indepenentistas. that the police has files on the independentistas. I mean, and that alone basically created this huge wave
“那就是我发现Cerro Maravilla中被杀的人之一是他的朋友。他们整个高中都在一起学习。那时我们才真正知道，嘿，这是认真的。”审判占据了广播频道，正是在收音机里，关于档案夹的真相终于大白。情报部门的一名警察在广播节目中激烈的争论中脱口而出。他说：“每个人都知道警察有独立派人士的档案。”那句话本身就引发了巨大的浪潮，
of investigations into the Carpetas and eventually court cases to release them. Initially, the government wanted to destroy the files. But in 1988, after enough public outcry and legal pressure, the Puerto Rican Supreme Court ruled that the Carpetas had to be released. As more and more files became public, a clear picture emerged. What had begun as surveillance of political enemies had later expanded into broader targets.
引发了对档案夹的调查，并最终导致了要求公开它们的法庭案件。起初，政府想销毁这些文件。但在1988年，在足够的公众抗议和法律压力下，波多黎各最高法院裁定必须公开档案夹。随着越来越多的文件公开，一幅清晰的图景浮现出来。最初作为对政治敌人的监视，后来扩展到了更广泛的目标。
People and feminist and even environmental organizations had been targeted by the police too. What has always struck me as an incredibly odd thing about my grandpa's carpeta, and all carpetas for that matter, is that after decades of surveillance, and all the violence, and everything else that had suppressed the independence movement, thousands and thousands of these files were just sitting in an office in San Juan. And when they finally made the surveillance public, they released the files to the people who had been surveilled.
女权主义者甚至环保组织也成为了警察的目标。关于我祖父的档案夹，以及所有档案夹，一直让我感到非常奇怪的一点是，经过几十年的监视、所有的暴力以及压制独立运动的一切手段，成千上万的这些文件竟然只是静静地躺在圣胡安的一间办公室里。当他们最终公开监视信息时，他们把文件交给了被监视的人。
If the government had opened a file on you, you could just drop by the office and pick it up on your lunch break if you wanted. And people did. Do you remember going to get it? And do you remember reading your carpeta for the first time and reading Abuelos? Yeah, we were surprised. We were surprised at the pictures they had. The thing to remember here is that my grandparents didn't commit any crimes.
如果政府为你建立了档案，你可以在午休时间顺便去办公室取走它。人们也确实这么做了。“你还记得去取它吗？你还记得第一次读你的档案夹和读祖父的档案夹吗？”“是的，我们很惊讶。我们对他们拥有的照片感到惊讶。”这里要记住的是，我的祖父母没有犯任何罪。
They were never violent. They weren't dangerous people. Their only crime was believing in independence. Still, people around them fed information to the police. People my grandma and grandpa trusted and loved. And when he started reading it, like, Oh my god, this son of a bitch, you know, squealed on me! Because it was people you knew. It was your neighbors.
他们从不暴力。他们不是危险的人。他们唯一的罪行是相信独立。尽管如此，他们周围的人还是向警察提供了信息。那些我祖母和祖父信任和爱的人。当他开始阅读时，“哦，天哪，这个混蛋，你知道，告发了我！”因为那是你认识的人。那是你的邻居。
Who was following you? Who the hell was the spy? That's what most people wanted to find out especially. Who's the spy? But it was everyone. When I spoke to my grandma, she told me that she and my grandpa looked through their carpetas, and after reading them, they just kind of went into storage. And to me, that's one of the craziest parts of this whole story.
谁在跟踪你？到底谁是间谍？这是大多数人最想知道的。谁是间谍？但每个人都是。当我与祖母交谈时，她告诉我，她和祖父翻阅了他们的档案夹，读完后，它们就被存起来了。对我来说，这是整个故事中最疯狂的部分之一。
These files were proof that the government had been spying on them, proof that their neighbors and friends had betrayed them, and they were simply handed back, read, and put in the back of a closet. Life was supposed to just go on. There was never a national moment of reckoning from the state in which there was a process in which people could think publicly and together about what this has meant for them. And so I think that it's still this open wound in Puerto Rico. Today the carpetas still loom in the Puerto Rican psyche.
这些文件证明了政府一直在监视他们，证明了他们的邻居和朋友背叛了他们，而他们只是被交还、阅读，然后放回衣柜深处。生活本应继续。国家从未有过一个清算的时刻，没有一个过程让人们可以公开地、共同地思考这对他们意味着什么。所以我认为这在波多黎各仍然是一个开放的伤口。今天，档案夹仍然笼罩在波多黎各人的心理中。
The word Carpetas is still used as a verb. If you're going out to a protest, your grandma might say, Cuidado, o te van a Carpetear, basically telling you that you better watch your step, or the government might start spying on you. Ultimately, the Carpetas did have a chilling effect on the independence movement and the nationalist party never participated in electoral politics again. But for people in the movement, the revelation of the files only strengthened the belief in their cause, because it was a tangible symbol of a broken political system.
“Carpetas”这个词仍然被用作动词。如果你要去参加抗议，你的祖母可能会说：“Cuidado, o te van a Carpetear”（小心，否则他们会监视你），基本上是告诉你最好小心点，否则政府可能会开始监视你。最终，档案夹确实对独立运动产生了寒蝉效应，民族主义党再也没有参加过选举政治。但对于运动中的人们来说，文件的披露只会加强他们对事业的信念，因为它是破碎的政治制度的有形象征。
That didn't stop us, because the moment we found out, the moment we got those Calpetas, and we knew what was going on, that only made us stronger. Because what are you going to do now? It's out in public. You can't come arrest me now just because I believe in the independence for my country. You know, hey you, I'm involved.
“那并没有阻止我们，因为当我们发现的那一刻，当我们拿到那些档案夹，知道发生了什么时，那只会让我们更强大。因为你现在能做什么？它已经公开了。你不能仅仅因为我相信我的国家独立就来逮捕我。你知道，嘿，你，我参与其中。”
Well, let's get involved." Eventually more people did get involved. Although the Nationalist Party did not run, a candidate from the Puerto Rican Independence Party received nearly one-third of the vote in the most recent gubernatorial election. It was a milestone for the independence movement. So many things have happened in Puerto Rico in recent years that my grandma thinks it's getting harder and harder to ignore the role the United States still plays in the island's troubles. Why? Because people are learning more. People are beginning to become so conscious of what they've been doing to us for so many years.
“好吧，让我们参与进来。”最终更多的人参与了进来。虽然民族主义党没有参选，但波多黎各独立党的候选人在最近的州长选举中获得了近三分之一的选票。这是独立运动的一个里程碑。近年来波多黎各发生了这么多事情，我祖母认为越来越难忽视美国在岛上麻烦中所扮演的角色。“为什么？因为人们正在学习更多。人们开始意识到他们多年来对我们所做的一切。”
For my grandma and so many others, the fight around Puerto Rico status has never been about the difference between being a Commonwealth or state, or anything like that. To her, Puerto Rico is Puerto Rico. It is its own nation, no matter what people say. That's the way my grandma sees it. And it's a fight she's going to continue until her last days. I will die for my country. I will believe in its independence because I believe in its people. We've been down.
对于我的祖母和许多其他人来说，围绕波多黎各地位的斗争从来不是关于成为自由邦还是州之间的区别，或者类似的事情。对她来说，波多黎各就是波多黎各。无论别人怎么说，它都是一个独立的国家。这就是我祖母的看法。这是一场她将持续到生命最后一刻的斗争。“我会为我的国家而死。我会相信它的独立，因为我相信它的人民。我们曾经被打倒。”
And you could bring me down, but I will not lick your boots. I will never be at your feet. And every time you bring me down, I'm going to get back up. This is me, this is where I come from. And nothing could take that away from me. When we come back, the evolution of the Puerto Rican flag.
“你可以打倒我，但我不会舔你的靴子。我永远不会跪在你的脚下。每次你打倒我，我都会重新站起来。这就是我，这就是我来自哪里。没有什么能把它从我身边夺走。”回来后，波多黎各旗帜的演变。
So we are back with Jacob Medina Gleason, who brought us that story and the story turned out great. But I do have a bone to pick with you because when you first pitched this story, it was about flags and this is not a story about flags. So tell me what happened. Yeah, I did. I did originally pitch the CEO as a flag story.
我们回来了，和Jacob Medina Gleason在一起，他给我们带来了那个故事，故事非常棒。但我确实对你有意见，因为当你第一次推销这个故事时，它是关于旗帜的，而这不是一个关于旗帜的故事。所以告诉我发生了什么。“是的，我确实。我最初确实把这个故事推销为旗帜故事。”
But sadly, as is often the case, sometimes while reporting a story, different angles come out and things have to get cut, and I'm sorry because I know you're the flag guy, but to make amends, I am here to talk flags with you, Roman. That's perfectly okay. I mean, I was present for the editorial process. I understand why the flags had to go,
“但遗憾的是，正如经常发生的那样，有时在报道故事时，会出现不同的角度，事情必须被删减，我很抱歉，因为我知道你是旗帜迷，但为了弥补，我在这里和你谈论旗帜，Roman。”“那完全没问题。我的意思是，我参与了编辑过程。我理解为什么旗帜必须被删掉，”
but I'm very, very glad that we're gonna talk about flags now. So please, let's talk about the Puerto Rican flag. Okay, so we've actually got a few flags. So we'll start with this first one. So this is a flag from 1868, and it's from the first time that Puerto Rico united under a flag while they were under Spain's rule. And so, Roman, I'm going to show you this flag, and you let me know what it looks like and if it reminds you of any other flags. Okay, so this flag, it has four quadrants that there's two blue rectangles at the top, two red rectangles at the bottom.
“但我非常非常高兴我们现在要谈论旗帜了。所以请，让我们谈谈波多黎各的旗帜。”“好的，我们实际上有几面旗帜。所以我们从第一面开始。这是1868年的一面旗帜，这是波多黎各在西班牙统治下第一次团结在一面旗帜下。所以，Roman，我要给你看这面旗帜，你告诉我它看起来像什么，它是否让你想起任何其他旗帜。”“好的，这面旗帜有四个象限，顶部有两个蓝色矩形，底部有两个红色矩形。”
They're all separated by a white cross that's centered in the middle. And at the top left blue canton is a big white star. And I would say this looks a lot like the flag of the Dominican Republic. Yeah, it's a great flag. Yeah, it totally does remind me of the Dominican Republic. I see that instantly. And the shades of red and blue are also really similar
“它们都被中间的一个白色十字隔开。在左上角的蓝色方块里有一颗大白星。我会说这看起来很像多米尼加共和国的国旗。”“是的，这是一面很棒的旗帜。是的，它确实让我想起了多米尼加共和国。我立刻就看出来了。红色和蓝色的色调也非常相似，”
to what you would find on the Cuban flag. A group of underground revolutionaries planned a revolt called El Grito de Lares. And part of the preparation was having a flag designed. At the time of El Grito de Lares, there were a few different nations that were all sort of fighting for their independence in the Caribbean.
“和你会在古巴国旗上找到的一样。一群地下革命者计划了一场名为‘拉雷斯呼声’（El Grito de Lares）的起义。准备工作的一部分就是设计一面旗帜。在‘拉雷斯呼声’时期，有几个不同的国家都在加勒比地区为独立而战。”
So it was really common at the time for people from one country to go to the other country, help them fight for their independence with the idea that these people would return the favor. So that's why the flags are so similar similar is because there was a lot of solidarity between these countries. But that's so interesting. It makes so much sense with what little I know of sort of revolutionary history of the
当时，来自一个国家的人去另一个国家，帮助他们争取独立，并希望这些人能投桃报李，这在当时非常普遍。这就是为什么这些国家的国旗如此相似，因为这些国家之间有着深厚的团结情谊。但这太有趣了。以我对该地区革命历史的浅薄了解，这非常有道理，
area, especially when you bring up Cuba, because one of the things I've noticed is that the current Cuban flag and the current Puerto Rican flag look pretty similar. Like when I'm in New York and they're both everywhere, I often get them mixed up. Can you tell me about the Puerto Rican flag, the version that we have today? Yeah, so the official flag of Puerto Rico is called the monostrellada, which means one star.
尤其是当你提到古巴时，因为我注意到的一件事是，现在的古巴国旗和现在的波多黎各国旗看起来非常相似。比如我在纽约时，到处都能看到这两面旗帜，我经常把它们弄混。你能给我讲讲波多黎各的国旗，也就是我们今天看到的那个版本吗？是的，波多黎各的官方国旗被称为“单星旗”（monostrellada），意思是“一颗星”。
It's got five horizontal stripes in red and white and a blue equilateral triangle with a white star on its left side. The Cuban flag is very similar, but the colors are inversed, so blue stripes, red triangle. And that's because La Monestrellada was created by Puerto Ricans in New York who were working alongside Cuban revolutionaries. This was late 1800s, early 1900s, and Cuba was about to gain their independence from Spain and Puerto Rico was hoping to gain their independence from Spain,
它有五条红白相间的横条，左侧是一个蓝色等边三角形，中间有一颗白星。古巴国旗非常相似，但颜色是反过来的，即蓝色横条、红色三角形。这是因为“单星旗”是由在纽约与古巴革命者并肩工作的波多黎各人创作的。那是19世纪末、20世纪初，当时古巴即将从西班牙获得独立，而波多黎各也希望从西班牙获得独立，
and Puerto Rico was hoping to do the same thing. And because of that solidarity between the two nations, they took the Cuban flag and just inverted the colors. And that single star was meant to represent these single independent nations that they hoped to become. Wow. So they're similar because they wanted to represent the solidarity between these countries, and so therefore they designed that into their flags. I had never known that. That's awesome. Yeah.
波多黎各也希望实现同样的目标。正是因为两国之间的这种团结，他们采用了古巴国旗，只是将颜色反转了过来。而那颗单星旨在代表他们希望成为的独立国家。哇。所以它们相似是因为他们想表达这些国家之间的团结，因此他们将这种理念设计进了国旗中。我以前从不知道这一点。这太棒了。是的。
Yeah. And so this flag, the Mono Seriala, it started out as the flag of the Independence Party, but it was actually co-opted by the Puerto Rican government. Oh, okay. So tell me more about that. Yeah. So as we talk about in the episode, in 1952, the status of Puerto Rico changed from unincorporated territory to commonwealth. And with that, Puerto Rico got to adopt a constitution and do all these state-like things.
是的。所以这面旗帜，“单星旗”，最初是独立党的旗帜，但后来被波多黎各政府收编了。哦，好的。那多跟我讲讲这个。好的。正如我们在节目中讨论的那样，1952年，波多黎各的地位从非建制领土变为了自由邦。随之，波多黎各得以通过一部宪法，并进行所有这些类似国家的活动。
And one of those things was to choose a flag. And what better way to try and take away the power from something than to have the government sort of co-opt it? Right, this is a classic move, yeah. It really is, yeah. But they did change one thing. Most of the Puerto Rican flags you saw before then had a really light, almost sky blue. It was meant to represent the Caribbean waters.
其中一件事就是选择一面国旗。还有什么比让政府将其收编更好的方式来削弱某种事物的力量呢？没错，这是一种经典手段，是的。确实如此，是的。但他们确实改变了一件事。在那之前你看到的波多黎各国旗大多是浅蓝色的，几乎是天蓝色。它旨在代表加勒比海的水域。
But when the Puerto Rican government adopted the flag to use as the official flag of Puerto Rico, they changed it to a deeper blue that would more closely align with the colors of the United States. Right. That makes sense. Yeah. The light blue is that makes sense, yeah.
但当波多黎各政府采用这面旗帜作为波多黎各的官方国旗时，他们将其改成了更深的蓝色，以便与美国的颜色更接近。没错。这说得通。是的。浅蓝色确实说得通，是的。
The light blue is really nice looking though. It kind of reminds me of the light blue of the Chicago flag. Yeah, it's beautiful. I like that version. I was actually just in Puerto Rico with my husband and we went into a souvenir shop and there were the two versions of the flag
不过浅蓝色看起来真的很漂亮。它让我想起了芝加哥旗帜的浅蓝色。是的，它很美。我喜欢那个版本。我实际上刚和丈夫去过波多黎各，我们走进一家纪念品店，那里有两个版本的国旗，
and my husband Billy asked me, he said, which version are we gonna buy? I told him, I said, it depends on if you believe in independence for Puerto Rico or not. So we bought the lighter blue, of course. That's a bold question to ask right there in the store. I was maybe setting him up a little bit. That's awesome.
我丈夫比利问我，他说，我们要买哪个版本？我告诉他，我说，这取决于你是否相信波多黎各应该独立。所以我们当然买了浅蓝色的那个。在店里问这个问题真是个大胆的举动。我当时可能是在给他设套。这太棒了。
Roman, I've got one last flag for you, are you ready? Yes, totally ready. So in 2016, the financial crisis in Puerto Rico hit a point where the governor had admitted that the debt was unpayable, and the federal government proposed a solution. It was a fiscal oversight board called PROMESA. They basically would take charge of Puerto Rico's finances and the members of PROMESA were not selected by the Puerto Rican people, yet they had the ultimate say on how Puerto Rico could spend its money to help pay down this debt. So overnight, basically, Puerto Ricans lost their autonomy and financial decisions were made by outsiders.
罗曼，我还有最后一面旗帜要问你，准备好了吗？是的，完全准备好了。2016年，波多黎各的金融危机达到了一个临界点，州长承认债务已无法偿还，联邦政府提出了一个解决方案。那是一个名为PROMESA的财政监督委员会。他们基本上接管了波多黎各的财政，而PROMESA的成员并非由波多黎各人民选举产生，但他们却对波多黎各如何花钱来偿还债务拥有最终决定权。所以一夜之间，波多黎各人基本上失去了自治权，财务决策由外人做出。
Yeah, I remember when that happened. And I remember that it really received bipartisan support here in the United States. They just treated this as a normal thing to do. Yeah, totally. And to a non Puerto Rican, it might seem like a completely logical fix. But when this happened, people on the island started to talk a lot about this idea of like the myth of the Commonwealth. Basically, this idea that this so-called independence that we had as a Commonwealth was always a myth because the U.S. could take it away at any moment. And people were really upset about this. So on July 4th, 2016, an anonymous art group called La Puerta went into Old San Juan and they painted over a door that previously had the Puerto Rican flag, but they painted it black and white.
是的，我记得那件事发生的时候。而且我记得它在美国确实得到了两党的支持。他们只是把它当作一件正常的事情来处理。是的，完全正确。对于非波多黎各人来说，这似乎是一个完全合乎逻辑的补救措施。但当这件事发生时，岛上的人们开始大量讨论“自由邦神话”这个概念。基本上，这种所谓的作为自由邦所拥有的独立性一直是一个神话，因为美国随时可以将其收回。人们对此感到非常愤怒。因此，在2016年7月4日，一个名为La Puerta的匿名艺术团体进入圣胡安老城，他们粉刷了一扇之前画有波多黎各旗帜的门，但他们将其涂成了黑色和白色。
And the idea was to show their dissatisfaction with what was going on on the island. And that symbol really took off. And in what way did it take off? Well, people started to see the black and white flag as that symbol of dissatisfaction, and also as a symbol of mourning over what was happening on the island. And a little over a year after the black flag appeared in Old San Juan, Hurricane Maria hit. And as you well know, the government response for Hurricane Maria was pretty pitiful, and as a result, thousands of people died in the storm and its aftermath. Yeah, yeah. I mean, this is one of those moments that your grandma Nancy talked about as being kind
其目的是表达他们对岛上所发生事情的不满。那个符号真的流行起来了。它是以什么方式流行起来的？嗯，人们开始将黑白旗帜视为不满的象征，也视为对岛上所发生事情的哀悼象征。在黑旗出现在圣胡安老城一年多后，玛丽亚飓风来袭。正如你所知，政府对玛丽亚飓风的反应相当糟糕，结果导致数千人在风暴及其后续影响中丧生。是的，是的。我的意思是，这是你祖母南希提到的那种时刻，
of eye-opening for people of the island to see like where they stood and vis-a-vis the United States. Yeah, 100%. People on the island and really around the world got to witness just how little the federal government seemingly cared about saving Puerto Ricans. Puerto Rico's own governor had texts leak of him making light of people who had died in the hurricane. It was really awful. And so in these protests, you could feel that people really wanted change. And what symbol was everywhere throughout all those protests? It was that black and
让岛上的人们大开眼界，看清了他们与美国之间的关系。是的，百分之百。岛上乃至全世界的人们都目睹了联邦政府似乎是多么不在乎拯救波多黎各人。波多黎各自己的州长被泄露了短信，他在短信中轻描淡写地谈论在飓风中丧生的人。这真的很糟糕。所以，在这些抗议活动中，你能感觉到人们真的想要改变。而在所有这些抗议活动中，到处都是什么符号？就是那面黑白色的
white Puerto Rican flag. So does this flag have the same sort of political ideas attached to it as like the light blue version of the sort of pre-USAF version of the independence flag? Yeah, interestingly, no. This flag, the black and white one, is not really as political. You sort of see it across people who are pro-statehood, pro-independence. It's really more an acknowledgment of the idea that something needs to change, that the way that things are
波多黎各旗帜。那么，这面旗帜是否像浅蓝色版本（即美国化之前的独立旗帜版本）那样，附带了同样的政治理念？有趣的是，并没有。这面黑白旗帜并没有那么强的政治色彩。你会在支持建州的人和支持独立的人中看到它。它更多是对一种观念的认可，即事情需要改变，目前的运作方式
going right now just isn't working. Wow. I'm so fascinated by the use of a flag to express that. It's one of the reasons why I'm so interested in flags and why I was so happy that you have come correct for this CODA to give me the flag content that I crave. Thank you so much, Jaka. I appreciate it. You're welcome, Roman. I'm glad you got your flag fix.
行不通。哇。我对使用旗帜来表达这一点感到非常着迷。这也是我为什么对旗帜如此感兴趣的原因，也是我为什么很高兴你能为这个尾声带来我渴望的旗帜内容。非常感谢你，雅卡。我很感激。不客气，罗曼。很高兴你得到了你想要的旗帜知识。
99% Invisible was reported and produced this week by Jacob Medina Gleason and edited by Jason DeLeon and Vivian Lay. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolosted is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube,
本周的《99% Invisible》由雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森报道和制作，杰森·德莱昂和薇薇安·莱编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由Swan Real创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科洛斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝，
Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California.
埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心，向北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。
You can find us on many social media sites like Blue Sky, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在许多社交媒体网站上找到我们，比如Blue Sky，以及我们自己的Discord服务器。在99PI.org上可以找到相关链接以及《99PI》的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。